6:9 like straight in the abode of yeah
that guy tattoos on his face around its
ass Capullo
why'd you look at my hair cuz I haven't
got the color for that I know I just
really imagine what people don't know
when they have not met Brian is this is
actually all tattooed dots he's bald as
a coot as they say in God like oh it is
actually her yeah it is real
[Music]
come here just put six nine on he's been
grossing everyone off basically he's
only 23 he's really [__] it up honey
really [__] it right me if ever you're
likely to make a mistake like this is
when you're very young yeah and that's
just a toast yeah it's a failure on his
part he's [__] up he's a young kid and
I think he got involved with some real
gangsters who manipulated him they used
him they eventually kidnapped him he is
quite small it's easy to bungle him in
about of a van in it and here he is yeah
all in prison with lovely hair he wanted
all of the clout and it's ended up
getting him locked up and now he's
having to cross I never liked even if he
gets out he could be a dead man within a
week his only option now was to go the
other way and be like look they tried to
kill me what would you do and try and
play it off with on it and try and win
the hearts of the people back but he
also named Hardy B as a member of the
gang which doesn't surprise me
considering some of the illegal [__]
she's done didn't she say she liked the
drug grandma yeah she did rape man basic
point weekend member yo she's like pop
pop okay when she visited that she was
like oh he got arrested and a day later
I'll quote me it wasn't like they
grilled him for like weeks on end you
know I mean he was I know but then when
you're facing like 18 years in prison
it's like do I take the fall for these
guys who've nearly just killed me do I
grass on them which a lot of you're not
gonna give him [__] but like they did
turn on him they did literally try and
kill him yeah and it wasn't like he was
like part of the group still and they're
like oh you need to shop well no he was
just a little face of what they've been
doing behind the scenes yeah exactly was
taking credit but he was never the
actual perpetrator I feel sorry for him
yeah do yeah but like everyone's gonna
give him [__] cause he's gross in and I
get that but like they literally
manipulated him to no end and then
turned on him at the end if something
happen to you where I was I do 10 years
in prison I mean I've seen no no
genuinely there's people in your life
who you did I go down for not on yes to
be just perhaps later the out of context
we ain't gay no we're not no we're not
going
we ain't gay I said you just hear what
you want sometimes I hear that so right
just to be clear though they try to kill
him right where's the shock they're not
citing a prison somewhere gone we were
so good to him yeah they know what
they've done ah the upon one minute back
of a [__] card-throwing the killer
the only annoying thing is I think a lot
of people take their own friendship
group and think that he's I am him
the if I went to prison it would be like
Ben and Andy at school like no he isn't
he's not friends with Ben and Andy okay
Ben an Andy a very different yeah you're
very different to you all right well
someone else is in prison no they're not
someone else is in court all right
Britney Spears
come have a look at Britney Spears for a
second before we even start I just don't
even want to jet if not I'm not
objectifying women you find women
it's just Britney Spears and I just want
to say when I was when I was a lad she
looks like a deflated Tricia pay also
that's not well that's very accurate
it's not incredibly accurate deflated
Trisha Paytas Trisha fail yourself this
oh my god I'll take that yeah also
deflate as' and then she was actually
just reaching for a cake there yeah
compliment as well yeah Armani job
function I'm gonna give Trisha some
credit later on so don't jump on me just
yet yes although can we give context for
when she was younger though because I
want people to say I hit me baby one
more time that video was what was the
other one that she did
Redd's yeah so when I was like a large
she's so sweet
no but this well there's a hint of
leeway the point is is when I was a lad
this is what I could quite fun seeder
probably where the BDSM [__] started
really the lyrics are not only Britney
Spears for your it's her fault Britney
space lately Spears became rich and
famous at a very young age she basically
needed her parents to look after our
money for our smarts well this is the
thing that never ended and no wow dad
I'm 14 is having her age which I mean
what does she know she looks 90 phobia
such cons but she does look older than
what she wants I know I'm funny I think
people get all the lines you don't age
at all actually we watched it all video
the other day yeah I've aged terribly oh
you haven't aged at all I'm the one
who's aging out of us it's so [__]
annoying yeah although I've lost a bit
of weight but forget you know that
she aid you quicker if anything you
should slowly get fatter you get older
slowly inflate you you know because
really the wrinkles yeah I'll just go
filler like all these other celebrities
sure or just eat and two more Burger
King I feel like they're effective
Brittany's dad controls the money cuz he
always did and now she's having to fight
it in court to get the rights to have
her own money at 37 years old she should
have been like how to control of that
since at least twenty-one yeah she's now
got to fight him for and the funds are
protesting can we have a look at the
slit knees fans think they're gonna make
any [__] difference Wow do with free
Brittany signs in hand fans marched
outside the Stanley Moss courthouse
today there's so much conservatorship
abuse that goes on not only in
Brittany's case but in so many other
cases you're talking about your own pain
I feel like it's about control money
from Ian Ian's like my dad yeah you're
talking a Britney now Ian's an [__]
my family has been going through a lot
of stress and anxiety lately so I just
need a time to do what the [__] no
wonder they won't let her have it it's
not what she's like no yeah tell me what
I know I need to watch more of this if
we were the judge yes we're judging it
purely off her Instagram videos would
you give up a control of the money let's
watch no okay you're not getting them my
salsa yeah solves it ya know move on we
need someone who's actually an adult
here Brittany not someone who's posting
Happy New Year guys we're hope you're
having a great time out there let's give
her another chance just give her another
one she isn't meant don't give her the
money she's mental don't have them she's
lost it you mean getting the money you
know one she's like that I don't know
about you you know any wiggle with a
girl that day after so like she did a
makeup the night before and it was
really good day but the day after he's
your life just like he's got any of
those wipes oh you can yeah Brian just
gives her a flannel like no no no do me
ask for that no no look it's just her
thing isn't it yeah she goes for that
sort of dirty
I used a paint gun to put my she's just
in great shape those yes not saying that
I just don't see women are exercising
often unless I'm on Instagram it's I
know I know histogram anymore to be in a
while on that wall you know one the
volume you don't need to see women
instagramming to know like
that they exercise I think I do Laurens
right moving on we feel sorry for
Britney Spears sorry Britney you see
this guy heartthrob for all presidents
out there see the Canada President or
what's he'd be into he's been doing
blackface Brian three times once is bad
enough
yeah no he's gone for the hot trip was
not he definitely didn't put it like
that in the press conference in and go I
had to do three times okay boy you
haven't been done for it the first two
so you go and do what I want have you
since been made aware or remembered of
other instances and if so how many I am
wary of being definitive about this
because the recent pictures that came
out I had not remembered no chase you're
probably drunk as further reelection
you're smart enough to get a be the
president of Canada by intercept and you
dress up at least three times that we
know of in blackface which is really
politically incorrect yeah do you
remember any of that nah don't remember
before we let you express we do with you
is the only thing you've done in the
past that we need to know about not the
best of my recollection what I'd like
about Canada though is it's a really
like relaxed place so they're probably
just gonna let him off with his children
yeah just completed a wreath at the end
of the deer drifted and he's from Canada
as well I don't think Drake's doing
blackface I think it's actually black no
he did blackface have you're not seeing
it tracheas black no no you're not
seeing this all right people aren't
doing but it's not whole people aroused
to recline goes to Jamaica and goes but
the other all doing it no have you not
seen the dish truck that was done Andre
called the story of added on wait until
you see this is real by the way
this is real no no not like this years
and he's dressed up as a he's a
light-skinned black man and he's gone in
doing blackface deficit black Mike
minstrel this is yeah obviously this was
an artistic thing that was done for a
long long time ago Justin Trudeau cannot
no no but he got ripped to shreds for
this yes he's black we're aware of that
fact Lawrence McKenna [__] he wants with
it yeah he can and it isn't that big of
a deal however fight it was it was used
the answer by Pusha T as an extra dig
ago it the whole thing about pushing T
is that Drake didn't feel like you
belong to a certain community yes
a way of furthering that dig on him see
I didn't think much of that I was more
you obviously had no clue about it so no
wonder you didn't think much of it you
didn't have a clue about it no album I
just well yeah well you should have
looked at the album cover I don't look
at you're hiding a child let their boy
come home remove that one that one yeah
and I think the question is how can you
not remember that yourself now I don't
remember that
how could you not right right I love it
where he's had to chat with his advisors
before he goes out and they're like just
so you don't remember his eye yeah but
they all can ask how do you not remember
that you're just gonna don't know this
is something that obviously I deeply
regret they never should have done all
right if he'd said that bit after saying
I do remember when I did it I was in
university I was drunk as [__] at the
time and I thought was funny and I'm an
idiot for doing that I'd have been like
all right you're a sort of a dick but
okay but the fact that he's denying even
remembering it that's a real cop in it
yeah I mean when you found the photos he
goes know when you're bummed arrives
right he has a lesson in life for that
from good old true Geordie yeah just
hold your hands up and say yeah I did
that [__] sorry yeah yeah what came out
of the press conference was mostly just
goo goo Gaga boo-boo Baba hate hate hate
googoo gaga I think what you mean is a
lot of interruptions and quite childish
behavior anyway this is backstage this
was actually from Jay Paul's camera
t-mobile you look and he's trying to mug
JJ off as he goes by but does he mug him
off let's see
your sewers too tight today it's okay I
know Taylor such a lame reply I know it
Taylor
although clearly you don't use it see
Jake is quite good at getting under
people's skin normally but that wasn't
his best you know I did like about it is
when jj-just Swagger's by ago don't be
nervous Jake don't be nervous it's
putting it in his mind of like this is
how I see you I see you as a nervous
person I see you as someone who's not in
control and I'm the guys in control I'm
giving you advice
don't be nervous Jake and Jake's is like
young no judges getting better at
hardness as anyone else putting some
interesting contributions to all of this
I feel like Jo well has actually been
really good recently you know yeah a
little bit good job see I miss Jo I
haven't seen him in a little while we
need to hook up yeah well you know Jo in
a friendly way yeah yeah I mean that's
how it starts seeing how obviously Eddie
Hearn and Matt from boxing have coming
understand he has seen the opportunity
there's loads of money to be made in
this and he's come through and said yeah
we're gonna get rid of all the youtubers
on the undercard and replace them with
professional boxing fights well I look
at the likes of a Nissen Gibb right
faced sensei jake paltrow Jordy did
mention you something yeah the phone
yeah I think it's implied though right
not to mention Eddie home ksi Logan you
wouldn't be getting any of this right
now if me and Fiona didn't have that
first boy that's kind of true yeah it is
partially true yeah not ooh noxee or
told because he was a part of it but it
was that first fight that first fight
proved something sold out the copper box
everyone was watching you might be the
first press conference millions upon
millions of years your deserves major
credit for see dude yes aleut Lee for
coming up with the sport but nothing
Joe's always good at because thinking of
good ideas he and bringing them to
YouTube and and also having the balls to
just go yeah I'm just gonna get in the
ring and start throwing punches and yeah
I didn't know much about boxing and went
for it nobody that courage is what it
needed yeah and he deserves this credit
I've heard of the people come to me and
say well we you could recreate that and
do with other people it'll never be the
same without logging in JJ the reason
why all those youtubers were willing to
fight on that undercard was to get the
clout from being with Lorna GG the the
reason everyone tuned in was for that
main event even though
we had a great fight in gibble versus
Jew and a great fight in Deji versus Jeb
Jake even though Eddie is kind of ripped
the heart and soul out of it through not
taking the other youtubers who are
really good all the commentators they've
proven that in terms of selling tickets
and getting pay-per-view numbers they
don't need anyone else but themselves
and I just hope that they're taking a
[__] huge wedge of money and not only
that but put this way what was the first
big podcast that lo kampala paid on boom
what did Logan Paul immediately after
the fight go and do set up a podcast
slogan where would you be without going
on I like your logic Joseph are you
saying we made love and Paul and may as
I'm saying Joe make him for boxing you
made him for voicing the truth comes out
we're gonna start our own podcast soon
true Paul Civ it's gonna be really good
to completely take this full circle
without Jake Paul involved this is a
very different card right but Jake Paul
is apparently trying to find someone Jay
Paul that's basically the only youtuber
who can walk in on this card because
it's like Eddie hostel eh oh the list is
Jake Paul Logan Paul any of the polls
he's now trying to find someone to fight
I personally think the list sucks apart
from any some get I disagree I think
Dylan Douglas would be a great fight for
G I think my sensei sensei would really
be a hard fight for Jake as well but for
me it's got to be good Gibble's the
natural choice because in terms of level
phases at pro MMA fights I believe and
Dylan Donna sees a real fight is a beast
so I'd love to say is how Jake handles
that non-stop pressure that gibble would
bring that would be interesting Jake
says our gibble isn't a big enough name
and again the thing that dead she
brought was the it was brother versus
brother instead she had a big subscriber
following but gibble he's like the
underdog in terms of social media status
but in terms of fighting styles he's the
favorite to win that fight it sort of
plays both ways yeah
all I'm saying is if by the time this
video comes out the survey still going
go vote it doesn't matter cuz you can't
see what the vote says anyways made it
so that only he can see it I believe
it's a bit like voting in the election
isn't it a sight well wield aside
conspiracy sin size 50 won favor like
[__] you got ours
next up Trisha Paytas oh yeah I want to
hear what she's being seen on impulses
with the
the motion capture they're going to put
another face on our video yeah Call of
Duty is one of the playable characters I
was saying everywhere
yeah we really felt like we captured
Trish's tits in a really good way for
this game she's done herself off and she
looks pretty good to do put diamonds all
over but she's made the fr icon the bad
guy from that's not be nasty we've we've
said a few things about throwing the
puss let's give us some nice espresso
whenever I break down he's literally
always calling me has no need nothing
from me because he's killing it you know
what I mean awesome yeah Jeffrey is
literally him and Jane are the only two
people on planet earth that like half
any sort of oh very cool Jeffrey star
yeah he's he's one of the two realest
people in the world him and Shane Dawson
they're the two realists really I think
she's aligned herself with them knowing
it and it she's just like yeah I'll go
sit with these guys yeah these guys he's
not he used to be but he's lost a bit of
with I think she's trying to put the
make like a backhanded compliment over
things or bait him out or if she
basically said I won't sit on that
chubby little dick I kind of liked the
fact that she sought us out there with
everything she thinks though like it's
just like the thing about Trisha it's
not really a filter between her brain in
her mouth and I'd rather someone just be
like Albany I don't know I don't know if
I could like handle her company for long
periods of time more than me but she
just speaks her mind and I rate that so
I'll give her that
interesting okay I've got a feel good
and a feel bad okay do you want the feel
bad first this is the feel and then I'll
cheer him on so this cop his body cam
shows him planting fake evidence while
searching people's cause and then
arresting them for when they had never
done anything I'm gonna be straight with
you
I don't feel like this man deserve to be
a policeman
there he is hiding it so he's planting
the [__] underneath and then putting the
stuff back in a long investigation can I
just say a yell on the first time he
does it just stop him you know me maybe
even a month why does it take a year ago
there he is again
you know 36 times he's done it this year
I think this time we lock this guy up do
you know the funny thing right is even
though they had actual footage of him
doing it they took a year to investigate
me I think it's the same police who are
investigating Biggie and Tupac smeared
on will get away will get away we just
want to listen to we're hit them up one
more time just to check is it definitely
Biggie's dissing I'm not so sure we've
got some other stuff we need to be
getting down to over here there's been a
couple of petty thefts that we need
doughnuts over there like what you doing
big I really hate people like that yeah
this one this one got me all right not
necessarily feel good but like I'm a bit
more like sensitive but you'll go you'll
go make sense you know I'm a diver it's
a diving story this one I never say it
diver finds GoPro with drowning victims
last moments incredible moment a diver
finds a GoPro camera at the bottom of a
lake incredibly the card inside the
camera wasn't destroyed and he was able
to recover several videos he soon
learned the images were the final
moments of a young man lost far too soon
he was told about this guy who died and
that he had a GoPro and that it might be
down there somewhere and he found it
just be clearly looks banged up but the
news reporters here are idiots it's a
waterproof case that this is in so
miraculously it's survived yes what
proof the reason I thought this was
feel-good it's because he recovered the
footage for the guy's family he was on
holiday the sky of something so they've
got lots of lovely footage and they know
how he kind of yeah but I mean aside as
it was if that was your loved one you
want all those happy little memory and
you see some of the happy times he had
before he died and he looks like he's
he's having the time of his life yeah
happy friends of this yeah he does look
like a cool guy I started say is that
this poor guys died young I mean that's
how you want your final moments anyway
you know in a way like is if you know
like he's he's so happy and all that
like if you found this footage in you or
the family if you're like look at him
like that's how I'd want to remember him
cold comfort but yeah a lot of people
lose loved ones and they don't have
anything like not many people get robbed
at gunpoint Bryan thankfully yes but
this guy definitely didn't get robbed at
gunpoint it would be a terrifying moment
for anyone an armed robber carrying a
shotgun enters a bar check out this guy
he calmly takes a sip of beer as
everyone around him dives for cover
under the bar then he looks at his phone
as if he doesn't have a care in the
world he's being called the world's
chile's man I love when news people say
things like that shoeless man he's the
world's chillest man and we're gonna
talk to him and as the gunman points the
gun directly at him he calmly lights a
cigarette this dude Tony Tony hey what's
your name my name's Tony Tony servo oh
shut up he says he remains calm because
quote I just had a really good feeling
he wasn't out to harm anybody I just I
guarantee later on in life this guy's
gonna be brutally murdered and you'll
not have reacted anything I'm good and
someone's gonna blow his [__] head
foolish foolish Tony Tovar the idiot who
went too far this has triggered a lot of
people you know when you walk in a room
and you say hey guys and there's women
and men in there she's here tell me why
this isn't right guys is a simple term
it could mean boys or if you're modern
hip it means people but it like many
male default terms should not be
normalized as an all-encompassing free I
use guys all the time I quite like the
term guys and I've got to admit there
are a few times where when I've been
addressing people in the room I'm gonna
hey guys that girl's gone what about me
and I've been like you're one of the
guys now shut up the men are talking
when I get back to the conversation with
the guys I wasn't talking to you [__]
[__] exactly yeah hey guys what about me
you don't matter for decades we have set
a standard of only addressing the men in
the room we set a precedent of only
addressing the men in the room that's
why when you know a show start ladies
and gentlemen yeah like she's talking
[__]
let the guy continue how is one to feel
empowered to speak or assert themselves
when upon greeting their misgendered or
even ignored in language well they're
supposed to understand that when I say
guys I mean everyone and I think if you
have a higher understanding you'll go
means me if you're smart enough to know
what the word misgendered mean then
you'll probably have a good
comprehension of what the word guys
means you probably also go when he walks
in there hey guys that I'm not just
walking in and going just be absolute
clear I'm only the men or loserman yeah
it's only the men that I'm interest
interested in here
the women are irrelevant all right and I
say that as a man can we be surprised
that for decades women often felt
uncomfortable asserting their voice when
we didn't even take the time to properly
acknowledge that I am yet to meet a
single woman who feels uncomfortable
asserting their voice that's what your
father I've never met one of you mad men
this is 2019 right have you ever met a
woman who's like I just don't feel
comfortable to say in my voice I've
never known one she's acting like it's
1912 year we're getting on the Titanic
but when you start valuing the
personhood and visibility of individuals
I'm not even laughs and what she's
saying here they're literally showing a
video of two men shaking hands and a
woman observing and as if somehow
overseeing the full seat I would like a
home to get [__] well I've like a
handshake well I'm sorry I'm just hand
shaking the guys now get to you we've
made decisions we've made a decision
yeah imagine dating a woman like this
when you use a thoughtful you come home
I have a hard day's work and I'll come
and she's I how was your day honey and
you're like yeah me and the guys were
just struggling well at the moment she's
like she's green behind so what we need
to have this chat again sorry what what
did you see what the [__] did you see
mmm don't make me play the video again
Brian oh I shouldn't laugh for other
people's misfortune Brian I love Clips
like this
false law is really cracking up I really
love the people feeling like has he got
any control over his hands and legs out
I mean if you're having to guide him on
the finish line on the starting line
then what the hell is going on and that
was this week's episode of true news
Thank You Lawrence thank you for not
falling off your bike and don't forget
hit like button stays subscribed to the
true Geordie youtube channel for more
and we'll Cesar